[Music]
do you ever think back to the early days
when you were just starting out scraping
by nobody knew who you were they didn't
care it is that those times come back
Wow wow that's that's deep man ah yeah I
think about those times all constantly
remember when you were nothing
you know I to see my parents exactly any
time around my family I mean I think
that uh you know look we're not when I
was starting out it was it was not good
it was not it was not a pretty picture
and and you know I I did not have a pot
to you-know-what in you know and no I
don't know what you're talking about
what I know what I'll tell you in the
commercial okay hey bro and like you
know I think you know I remember there
was this in the beginning I remember I
was I just moved to LA and I didn't have
anything and I loved the white stripes
love that man right and yeah yeah I'm
over there playing at the Greek Theatre
right and I really wanted to go I
couldn't afford a ticket and I just want
to be there so bad and I realized that
there's no roof on that theater so I
said you know life gives you lemons you
make lemonade right so I bought a couple
of 40 ounces of liquor and I went to the
Greek Theatre and I figured if there's
no roof I could sort of make my own
concert just sit outside and hear it you
know what I mean right and I thought was
cool so I took a seat on the sidewalk
and I had my beer and I just sort of had
my own concert and remember I'm sitting
there and Seth Green and Macaulay Culkin
we're walking up and I'd done a movie
with Macaulay Culkin's girlfriend I just
had a real little part I remember you
don't really know you don't know you
don't know these people
I mean I don't know I remember everybody
called him Mac and I thought that that
was like the cool thing so I said hey
Mac how you doing and they walked over
and they said hey man and I was like wow
look at this and they said what are you
doing here I told him and Seth Green
said well today's your lucky day and he
handed me a backstage pass to go see the
white stripes right how cool is that
right and then about I don't know ten
years later I done the walking dead and
I get a call that he wants me to do a
voice on his animated show so I show up
I get there I walk in he says wild man
I'm a big big fan I say whoa whoa whoa
whoa seth Curry and let me tell you
something and I told his whole crew
there about how he had given me that
backstage pass right
he said we sing and that was you I
thought that was a homeless guy
[Laughter]
you